you know
i would say mike is one of the better
impression guys that i know uh
marsha's really good impressions you
think it's the real people i mean i'm no
anthony cumia but you know
okay so shut up so uh
mr anthony coombie but all of his will
hello
i'm ronald reagan well there's this
gentleman uh he's
the pete palmer program and boy oh boy
is he funny
i have a feeling this guy's not gonna be
funny hold on no i heard him
come on give him the time i already hate
him somebody pointed out today
that it looked like he was doing a show
from a tgi fridays
from the bria from that little corner
yeah where they usually put the eight
top
so uh i mean yeah you're right though it
really looks like a tgi friday
so let's set it up let's set up this
show mo's family feedback
is that where he's doing the showroom
you like a bunch of crap on the walls
all right here you go give it a chance i
hate him
having a good time on the pete palmer
program it's a party everybody's here i
feel i i feel great everybody's here i'm
surrounded by so much love and joy
and uh all my friends you know so let's
see america
america's first batch of eggnog was made
in
james in the jamestown settlement in
1607
its name comes from the word grog
meaning any drink
made with rum non-alcoholic eggnog is
popular now keep keep an eye on how many
times he says eggnog
as well that's like a side note i'm
sorry so you know any drink made with
rum
is called grog i don't know if you knew
that or not but it is
uh according to what's with the music
okay so he just does a youtube show
i mean i've really tried he's trying to
make it sound like he's coming back from
break from a morning zoo show it's very
awkward what's with all the signs
some of them he had to have stolen right
they have to be
like sprinkler room these are i mean
props for stealing stuff
yeah i'm all for stealing [ __ ] from
buildings since it's hilarious but
what are you doing why are you hanging
what is there enough signs
get ready for you love impressions he's
gonna do a good mike tyson one okay
nine uh want to know a useful way to
recycle your christmas tree
well some zoos take donated trees for
like a month
other i get them uh let them feed the
animals with it oh ladies and gentlemen
here we go here we go
mr mike tyson hey mike how you doing
you ready yes already i'm bracing
myself because this is gonna be
so bad i can feel it
i'm doing great
[Applause]
why does mike why does mike tyson have
my toys
why does mike tyson sound like a muppet
character no one better than great
i'll tell you what every single fight i
had last month
i'd be feeling like a new man well
that's great mike it's great
i like how he switches the camera angle
so you know who was him and i'm mike
tyson
i'm not toy sir i fought a video i
filled i like toys is that mike tyson or
is that
animal it's my toys an animal from the
muppets white toys
is what he's doing he's doing a miss
piggy impression
mike tyson's like one of the easiest
ones dude
how are you not get how are you not
getting mike tyson
that's what i said earlier he sounds
like march simpson because mike tyson's
like a hack impression like anybody can
do a lisp and bring their voice up
because mike tyson is very easy to talk
like this
why my phone misunderstood because it
because it's because of the because
because i would beat people up and i
would talk about
journalists [ __ ] kids that's not what
mike's gonna tell the journalist he
could
[ __ ] you right in front of you and eat
his [ __ ] [ __ ] that's not what mike
tyson sounds like
it's not it's this is mike tyson this is
what mike tyson sounds like
by the way mike tyson is garbage but
like
it's easy it's just you you just gotta
talk like this and say like i don't
understand why
people get so uncomfortable when i talk
about [ __ ] dicks
and then like murdering their wives in
front of them
that's all not i i'm migration
it's gonna be a little high it's my toy
since appear now i
this guy could still turn it around for
me he does i think he does
the only way i'll i and i will give this
guy some advice
if he wants to have a good show sure i
would like you
if every one of your impressions sounds
like that then it would be funny right
if he just kept doing like oh you know i
was just thinking like you know what
would johnny carson have to say about
that he'd probably be like
hey ed hi i'm johnny carson and i'm
uh you know welcome to the show
that would be great that would be really
funny
whoa guys i'm here right now with
special guest david letterman
hey i'm david letterman where's the band
did you see that show last night paul
and then puzzle i did see it dave dad
everyone just sounded like i like then i
go you know what this guy's actually
that would be a funny bit if this guy
just every impression was
yeah it's like uh you know look i'll be
honest with you you know i'm not i don't
like to get too political or anything
but you know a lot of people are happy
to see trump out of office
but don't you just kind of miss like
turning on the tv and you know you see
him standing in front of the helicopter
and he'd be all like you know
dr falchi says you gotta get a vaccine
okay this guy's great i would laugh like
okay that's pretty funny bit
here so i mean i i saw the fight i mean
uh i have to say you know i mean
i'm not making any jokes of course you
know everybody oh trust me we know
you're not making any jokes
why are there so many people that want
to do a podcast that have
nothing to say i mean you know who does
have a podcast
mike tyson my toy she has a boy
i just
he's older and maybe it's a little
slower but you know you looked good you
looked really good shape and you
held your own are you talking to him
directly though too
mike tyson excuse me oh cause he's in
the room he's doing it he's talking oh
he's interviewing
he's interviewing him yeah he's throwing
you're right the distance and uh you
know
wow somebody doesn't really know radio
that well mike uh this guy's gonna teach
you a thing or two
about the radio business jesus christ
come up pay attention
it was a pleasure to to watch i have to
say well i want to thank you so much i
know
what is he is he this guy's serious
i'll show you some more of his videos
he's serious
he's doing
stephen crowder's impression of bernie
sanders
okay always been a supporter
of me here on this show and i appreciate
that and we've always been friends and i
like that and i appreciate that too
and it just gave me so much vigor to say
to myself
i'm a man again i was always a man don't
get me wrong because if anybody look me
cross
i bust your head up and it's no problem
that's not even how tyson talks
i'm a fan of mike tyson that's a spot on
mike dyson i bust
their head up yeah
that's not how tyson would like i would
understand even if he was saying like
the words right but just doing the voice
terribly but that
he does he's not even good at like
saying things because like part of an
impression is getting the voice down
the other part of an impression is
saying things that
sound like things that person would say
and bust your head up is not something
that he would
say i was able to recapture some of what
i
in my youth and it's made me think and
reflect because so many people out there
he sounds like he's doing an impression
of who the [ __ ] are you
yep yep he does sound like a cross
between pesci and gilbert godfrey
yes they start to get older and they
think to themselves
i can't do it anymore i'm washed up
there's nothing so this guy makes these
videos but then like
there's more he's good he shows so he
sends these to like his friends and
family he's like oh you check this out
i'm do you know you know how i've been
doing a podcast you got to check out my
tyson bit
you know he's been sending that to me
and then his own friends have to be like
wow that's
that's really good do you want us do you
want to see him uh channel dead
celebrities
trumpet guy and marge simpson somebody's
saying waste any time
who the [ __ ] are you oh man
homer i don't wanna after i fought
holyfield
so this this i've been a homie i bit off
holy fields a year
this isn't channeling dead celebrities
okay okay remember his name is
the pete palmer program oh he's bald too
yeah he's been bald he looks like
[ __ ] who's um guy guy that always just
hang out with kumia
[ __ ] man it's gonna bother me he's a
[ __ ] long island comedian that like
joe curry joe curry he looks like joe
curry
predictive astrologer and channeler of
the p palmer program
how you doing raymond nice to have you
here hello yes it's wonderful to be here
raymond starr i don't know who that is
so good it's been a little bit of a
little while i think i would see her
back at this raymond star harvey
fierstein maybe
beginning of january to give our uh
update uh
some uh extra okay he's about to channel
somebody here we go
of course hello great to be here today
peter thank you so much
well no but let me set it up you didn't
hear me set up let's set it up
no no mike mike mike you can't eat my
complete come back up
get back up go back up man come back up
i i this is douche chill city man i am
so uncomfortable i'm very comfortable
the spirits to come to me and see who's
going to enter
he's disassociating that's good
of course hello great to be here today
peter thank you so much for having me on
your show
oh my god it's sean connery ladies and
gentlemen
you know an impression is really good
you have to say the name right
not even when you have to say the name
because saying the name during the
impression is cringe but also having to
do the impression right and then go oh
my god it's sean connery
it's the other guy like nobody there are
impressionists that are so good
they just do the impressions right god
damn that guy's good
sean oh my gosh haven't seen you in so
long well i mean i'm
kind of seeing you but it's really great
to be here great great to have you here
how's
how's everything going you're enjoying
the afterlife yeah so cool
you know aside from being dead i have to
say that
i'm enjoying the afterlife there she's
not even a scottish accent
it's not even a scottish he's just going
of course
first off this is why of course this is
how you do sean connery
hey i'm sean cartery i know it's james
boy
honestly if i was james blood if he did
that
he'd be a genius like honestly i would
watch this guy's show on ironically and
i'd go
bro i love you i was like i literally i
love the impression
but he's really trying and they're this
bad
beautiful women up there in heaven oh
wow so you've made some uh
female friends and you make a joke about
the slapping them at least you're gonna
do
something well let's see i haven't seen
this one so honestly i don't know this
one haven't seen
well not quite yet i've seen some uh
some
of which available but uh of course uh
i'm on a waiting list
uh to get into heaven uh so i haven't
quite made it there yet
oh my gosh so you you passed on and what
you got rejected at the gates and you're
on a waiting list or
what happened weird premise stylish as
you know uh being long-time
hollywood person is my shelf and a lot
of things that go on
behind the scenes in hollywood show uh
i'm repenting as it were for a few
before
uh i'm allowed i'm allowed in but uh of
course
uh i am very confident that i will be
there and be with those beautiful
viewers where's the [ __ ]
jokes though like all right so this guy
doesn't do good impressions
but he also doesn't write any jokes for
this
like this is another one of those guys
and i've told you guys about this before
you know these guys that do a show like
and then they go like
you know what i'll do man i'll just wing
it you know what i mean off the dome
like because i'm so fun i'm like a funny
guy
i'll improv all of it and it's like i
want to say this right now
you know all those people that you see
on tv or the people you see doing sketch
like
improv like not bad sketch improv i mean
when
i know we like the [ __ ] on improv and
ninety percent of it is terrible
but there is good improv you can go see
it sometimes you're like wow those guys
are good
who's line who's lying who's lying is
girly whose line was great
honestly at one point ucb was pretty
good
at one point it's not good now whatever
but like
okay so whenever you see these guys and
you go wow look at the way they riff
they riff so good you do understand
right that like
they're riffing all the time they're
doing open mics they're doing like all
these shows
so they come up with stuff over time
it's the same way these old-timey
comedians
would do crowd work but like a lot of
the [ __ ] they said to the crowd
stuff they've said at 100 other shows
you just have like
you build a database of things that seem
improved
but like these guys watch that and they
go oh yeah those guys just riff dude
it's right off the dome i could do that
so he's but he's not he's got nothing
he has nothing somebody says he looks
like a grown up temple
really happy to have you here today we
haven't we have a new one
yeah gee i wonder who that is you know
who that is
mike tyson that's mike tyson it's mike
tyson
mike tyson's in the studio
oh [ __ ] by the way somebody mentioned
come town
yeah honestly come down is the funniest
show when it comes to riffing
but let's also not pretend that 90 of
come down is just
what if joe biden was gay like it is
i've seen
i i actually saw i saw come town but the
other day was called saturday night live
yeah they're stealing a lot from that
show all right
let's here's michael jackson all right
i'm happy to be here too it's always
nice and i just want to
send a little message i'm here today to
say don't forget
this also isn't a good impression
another this by the way
another low hanging one this should be
it's not the best
if you're gonna do a mike tyson
impression you're gonna go who i'm sorry
who no it's a lie
it's the ch you said you said mike tyson
you met mike jackson oh michael jackson
okay
no it's those they were trying to wrap
their tentacles around my fortune
they said i was your child molester they
were doing what was called
putting what they do on me
[Laughter]
that's right david geffen's trying to
call me a pedophile that's rich
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude but the thing is is like this isn't
even a guy who who like
okay has he's had to have done this
impressions for his friends right
now go ahead hobo chili recipe says it
is a great conkey impression
it's cocky but he doesn't have any
friends like to tell him hey man your
impressions suck
well no he don't well i'm sure he has
friends but like
this this goes back to something i've
been [ __ ]
banging the drum about on nightway for
months now it's we
now live at an age where nobody wants to
be
honest nobody wants to be uncomfortable
for five minutes
and tell somebody the truth so we all
just tell everybody everything's great
because it's easier because you don't
lose your job you don't get in trouble
you don't get canceled nobody gets mad
at you so you can just go yeah like
yeah it's great and and channeling some
of these uh here's another people
yes actually i have i do have one more i
feel i was
i i feel it coming it was this one
reached out to me a little bit
earlier today who is this guy i gotta
i'm obsessed
i mean i've looked him up i don't have
much information other than the show
that he's done
uh his name is the pete palmer program
palma program this guy's good man yeah
the pete pete palmer
i got to subscribe to this guy yeah oh
damn i got you man don't worry about it
here i'll give you the no no no
no i'll give you the links you can
subscribe no don't do it because
so here you go here's the link for him
if you want to subscribe did you look
him up
he does it trump he does do it trump
march 13th 2021 uh
donald trump usa update
wait where is it uh under his videos
uh march what march 13th uh
go up a little bit yeah just control
effort hold on
uh there it is right there third from
the the
third from the left on the second row
i better check it out here to make sure
but ladies and gentlemen it does appear
that we do have our very own president
donald trump former president former
president
donald trump president sir how are you
great to have you here
i'm donald trump i was the president of
america
all right here we go
wonderful to be here fantastic please
with that music please with that music
please
yes i got it i got it right here i'm
sorry i'm sorry mr president i know you
you don't care you know you've told me
before you heard that song a lot it kind
of gets you on your nerves after a while
you know it's true that you hear the
song it's always
hell of the chief i'm the chief but at
the same time oh wow that's really bad
like everybody does the trump right
everybody has a trump my trump is
terrible
um but this is a
spectacularly bad trump
this guy does impressions you think it's
the real people
you know this guy does impressions the
way
i play basketball right like i'm not
gonna
show up to the court with my socks
pulled up to my knees
to a bunch of black guys and be like
come on let's go we're playing for the
court today boys
try to keep up like he's not
good at impressions so why is he making
this his
his thing why is he making this
i don't know his thing but he but he's
really into it
you know there's a lot of people out
there right now a little confused not
sure what's going on they're
thinking maybe maybe somebody else is
running the country
but i want to come here today because
since today is the
start of an impeachment trial number two
he doesn't even do
you're not even doing it right get
this is a really bad donald trump like
my donald trump's always been lazy
and bad on purpose like i just it's just
how i do it because i'm not gonna like
sit there
i'm not gonna sit in front of a mirror
and go uh i'm gonna do that
like i would never do that see alec
baldwin so yeah but that's what he does
because you know he did
uh did it uh
my fake mexican wife like driving her
[ __ ]
spanish fake spanish whatever get it
right they're all the same
um but i never tried like this guy
want like plus the other thing is like
people go oh yeah emerson does all good
impressions but like
i don't consider myself a guy who does
impressions like they come up something
you're regular rich little
but like it's just i've always been a
guy that when i'm talking about like
when i'm quoting somebody
i imitate them like it's just i've
always mimicked people because it's just
funnier to do and you're telling a story
so like it just comes out but i've never
once practiced or been like
i'm gonna go on tour and do all my
impressions like that's never been a
thing
um but this guy's like i'm an
impressionist with all my clips i'm
doing impressions and he's not
good at it i don't understand that you
want to try to get him on the show
oh dub's saying marky mark i do know i
do
feel it feel it come on come on
okay so you know that this bit's never
gonna end now right
you gotta get up four in the morning
practice every day
like when i did boogie nights i had to
practice having a big dick
every day i had to get up and practice i
had to will it
i just sit there and think mark you got
the biggest dick in the world
way bigger than donny's
number two for donald trump first time
in history a lot of first time in
history is
with this presidency uh mostly good
things but of course
you know uh you are not doing the
over-enunciating
first of all operation warp
speed uh there's one more i wanted to
show you i have to
have to find it hate this sky man i
actually feel bad for him
why because there's so many people
called jealousy marsh
nah there's just like i get it dude like
crazy you know i i can't imagine
that if if we didn't do this show and
things didn't go well that i would be in
a great place
i understand everybody wants to do a
show now
uh sarah silverman did you see that
tweet this week on hey guys what do you
want me to stream about
and i retweeted it and i'm like if
you're thinking it that way then you're
doing this backwards please don't stream
um because this is a problem that a lot
of people have they'll be like
hey guys i want to start a podcast what
should i talk about like
more people put the cart before the
horse like
most people go hey guys i want to do
youtube
but i don't really know what i want to
talk about or do
and that's like completely the opposite
you're supposed to be somebody
that either really knows films or
really likes to walk around gas stations
in the hood and play the n word on a
speaker you got to have a passion for it
before you decide what place you're
going to do it in and how you're going
but like like this guy just wants to you
could tell he just wants to do a show
but like rosie has no friends nobody's
telling him like this isn't good
and he's gonna keep like it's almost
this is why
lying to people just to save yourself a
headache or to protect their emotions
it's a [ __ ] up thing to do to people
and you shouldn't do it
even if it's gonna be a little awkward
and they're gonna be mad at you at first
like
tell people they're bad at things save
them the energy save them all this
effort this poor [ __ ] guy is going
live
and trying to get these people every day
and he's bad at everything he does
because he doesn't have a single friend
that goes yeah you're bad at this
sex and chocolate has a good point the
mercy just can't handle competition
that's what it is you're right i mean of
course they're going to come after you
can't
you know commit those kind of atrocious
acts and
and then expect that you're just going
to walk away from it like unscathed
oh my god oh this is john travolta but
like
it's like not my fault or something it's
like where do i know i was just john
travolta right like here i was i was
so you know what i did today because
this is the one that i was introduced to
on date wave
i called john our buddy john
i called him without anything i he
didn't know i was calling him and i just
said john
john travolta right now he came in the
perfect john travolta impression and
then
i hung up on him i was like see without
even trying
john will [ __ ] crush a john travolta
impression oh yeah he's the best at it
yeah
not to vote that was a little boy right
and then i was growing up i was going to
school
somewhere like i walked to school i walk
home from school or something like that
it's so crazy right
and then i said oh john travolta like to
dance you know it's like who stay in
line stay in love with joshua do we just
dance
like for himself or something jojo did
dance for other people so the thing with
this guy is like
um so the thing with this guy is
and the more i've gotten into him i
thought it was just very very good
uh what i've really what i find weird
about him is like so a lot of the times
you find these people and maybe some of
these people you know we've run across
people on the spectrum
this guy's a normal guy like he's not
somebody that's on the spectrum he's not
[ __ ] he doesn't have down syndrome
he's just a guy who really [ __ ]
thinks that he's awesome
uh but anyway people aren't lying like
people are lying to this poor guy and
telling him he's good
this is because he and again you all do
this and you all do it because none of
you want to [ __ ]
be mildly uncomfortable for a few
minutes nobody wants to just go like
yeah you're not good at this like i'm
not saying don't stream and i'm not
saying don't do a show but
either get good at impressions or
try something else like him doing this
is like me insisting that i'm gonna get
to play for the raise
if i just keep practicing every weekend